hey guys I had a question about intermittent
fasting and when to exercise okay so let's
just talk about this for a second you know the
whole goal is to drain out the excess fat that
you have right other goals would be just to feel
better and get fit but maybe mainly people want
to lose weight and so they'd start adding
intermittent fasting ketosis and they start
adding these things typically the big mistake is
adding too many things too fast in other words
trying to go to two meals a day run off the bat
and exercising on top of it and they crash and
burn so I think the the ideal indicator to know
if you're doing it right is how you feel when
you start to exercise and you actually go through
it your legs heavy do you feel tired do you feel
like I can't go on or do you feel like you have to
reserve it you can do it that's the best indicator
to know that you're being able to handle it as
far as the timing goes I don't suggest if you're
doing cardio or interval interval training to
do it early in the morning if you're going to
wait if you're in the fast period because you're
going to deplete your glycogen Reserve and if
you're not ready for it you have to adapt to it
you're going to feel you're going to get really
hungry okay and you're going to feel light-headed
hypoglycemic type reaction so I always recommend
doing the exercise unless here really really fit
just before the meal during the the eating period
okay between the first and second meal the first
second and third meal or just like me I exercise
right after the the last meal of the day okay
that's perfect because you have the glycogen
reserve you have the food there to satisfy so
you have the energy to work out okay now this
is are you going to burn more fat verses here
versus here there's a couple studies and you
can burn a little bit more fat if you workout in
the evening because of the the sleep cycles okay
it's not that significant so but it's a little
bit more some people need to add more protein
when they workout like they're not doing any any
protein at all so when you workout you break down
your protein you're supposed to build up if
you don't have the amino acids if you don't
have the protein there you can feel a little
bit weird so you want you may want to adjust
the protein a little bit or even add a meal if
you feel really kind of ravenously hungry and
you can't handle your just going too fast okay
that's all so some people add creatine okay so
which is a it's a it's a supplement that you
can add to improve recovery I like it it's good
if you want to actually improve your recovery
if you're trying to maybe develop more muscle
mass you can add that and it doesn't necessarily
have to be with the meal okay I hope that answered
that question and put your comments below hi guys
hey listen I created a pretty amazing evaluation
quiz down below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root cause
of all of your symptoms the most likely cause
so take the quiz now and we'll send you report